sono tornata ieri da un brevissimo
viaggio a palermo con un gruppo di
studenti stranieri che hanno scelto
questa città come destinazione del loro
viaggio annuale il loro viaggio studio
annuale e vi chiederete perché è un
gruppo così variegato abbiamo scelto
questa città oltre che per il clima in
realtà palermo quest'anno è la sede di
due eventi molto interessanti il primo
nazionale la capitale culturale italiana
è un'iniziativa del ministero dei beni
culturali per valorizzare il patrimonio
delle città italiane con un occhio però
a quella che la valenza sociale della
cultura
l'altro invece è manifesta si tratta di
un evento internazionale quello che è
definito un evento itinerante di arte
contemporanea in cui gli artisti sono
chiamati a creare con il contesto in cui
la manifestazione si si realizza in
entrambi i casi quindi quello che mi
piace sottolineare e questa relazione
fra cultura e società
ma prima di andare avanti ed esplorare
insieme a voi questa questa connessione
vorrei fare una brevissima parentesi su
quello che è il concetto di cultura che
vorrei usare in questa brevissima
chiacchierata mi piace infatti fare
riferimento a un concetto di cultura
poco tradizionale e molto ampio dove
vado dal patrimonio tangibile a quello
intangibile dalle arti visive a quelli
al teatro alla musica ma dalla musica
classica a quella elettronica dalle
tradizioni alla cucina dalla
dall'architettura alla moda per esempio
e tornando a palermo il motivo per cui
questi studenti sono nate li dimostra
che la cultura può essere un fattore di
attrazione turistica
solo che non può non basta con voi
vorrei esplorare una connessione che va
oltre questo il turismo è in realtà
vorrei esplorare quella che è un'idea
ormai molto diffusa nei documenti
nazionali internazionali delle
organizzazioni che si occupano di
cultura in un documento dell'unione
europea di qualche anno fa che fa
riferimento al patrimonio
si parla il patrimonio come di uno
strumento per innanzitutto qualcosa che
viene dal nostro passato ma che dobbiamo
trasmettere alle generazioni future ma è
anche uno strumento di coesione sociale
e di sviluppo economico per la creazione
di posti di lavoro di fonte di
ispirazione per gli artisti ma anche
base per le industrie culturali e
creative quindi una enorme sfaccettatura
tanti ruoli per per il patrimonio
diciamo questi ruoli e sono importanti
da investigare anche e soprattutto
appunto questa connessione con la
società può sembrare automatica e
interessante da investigare ma poi non è
così automatica in economia della
cultura si usano tanto i dati per
cercare di comprendere quella che è la
partecipazione alla cultura da parte
della del pubblico per esempio per
esempio scusate una cosa che si utilizza
sono i dati sui visitatori dei musei e
delle mostre più visitate al mondo
questi sono i dati che vengono
pubblicati ogni anno dal dear science
paper è una rivista di riferimento per
il mondo dei musei dell'arte
contemporanea delle mostre che fa queste
classifiche sicuramente di nuovo dai
canoni della cultura utilizziamo i dati
ci servono a semplificare a capire qual
è il museo più visitato anche se
attenzione non basta sapere se uso e
molto visitato per capire quanto è
efficiente per questo gli economisti
alla cultura fanno molto e molti altri
studi che però non arrivano mai
in questo in questo tipo di
pubblicazioni perché sono un po più
complesse e si tratta
l'aspetto che però mi interessa di nuovo
di nuovo scusate di nuovo sottolineare è
bastano questi dati a capire quello che
l'impatto sociale della cultura
poco fa facevo sottolineavo quello che
il rapporto cultura e società
allora se con questi dati noi siamo
sicuri che il louvre tanto visitato a 8
milioni digitatori almeno l'anno
possiamo dire che quel museo che vediamo
quasi vuoto non
e abbastanza importante guardate che non
è una domanda scontata una domanda ovvia
perché quando parliamo in cultura
normalmente parliamo di finanziamento
pubblico e la cultura in italia europa
in moltissimi altri paesi per esempio il
giappone
la cultura è finanziata con denaro
pubblico e soprattutto all'indomani
della crisi quello che è successo è
diventato sempre più necessario
dimostrare che i fondi e la collettività
utilizzati per la cultura sono ben spesi
ma possiamo dire che i visitatori ci
bassano a per indicare se son ben spesi
questi fondi ci basta un numero mi
piacerebbe tanto visto che una parte di
me un economista però so bene che i
numeri i dati non bastano a cogliere i
valori della cultura la cultura infatti
presenta tutta una serie di
sfaccettature e tanti valori che non
possono essere sintetizzati in un numero
in un dato così semplice e per provare a
esplorare questi altri valori vi
proporrei di utilizzare tre termini il
l'incontro la cooperazione e la co
creazione
si tratta di tre termini che a mio
avviso vanno sempre di pari passo la
l'incontro è seguito in maniera quasi
automatica dalla cooperazione dalla co
creazione si fa un passo avanti si crea
qualche cosa di nuovo
può sembrare un po astratto vorrei farvi
vedere degli esempi che forse possono
chiarire tutto questo
il primo è una stele conservata alla
zisa scusate se vengo dalla quindi
palermo tornerà molto stesso e una spesa
in quante stelle in quattro lingue e
quindi testimonia quello che è il
passaggio di quattro popolazioni che
hanno abitato la palermo araba normanna
ma questo incontro non si eliminato non
è stato solo registrato su un pezzo di
marmo scusate la semplificazione
questo incontro è quello che ha dato a
vita edifici come san cataldo la
cappella palatina che sono un esempio di
sincretismo che ha dato vita a un unicum
riconosciuto come tale anche dall'unesco
tanto che questi dopo questi monumenti
sono stati inseriti nella lista del
patrimonio l'umanità qualche anno fa
l'incontro è anche quello di un gruppo
di turisti giapponesi che visitano
parigi da questo tipo di incontri può
nascere una qualche forma di contamina
in realtà è nata perché se pensiamo
all'europa del diciottesimo secolo
l'incontro con la cultura giapponese ha
fortemente influenzato gli artisti
europei per esempio van gogh alla mia
africa corsi van gogh che si è ispirato
ai rossi che per questa rappresentazione
del giardino di prugne e è ancora un
tipo di incontro che per me è molto
importante è quello dei bambini col
passato e con l'arte questo tipo di
incontro un incontro che può in qualche
modo stimolare facilitare la capacità di
apprendimento ma è un incontro che può
rafforzare il senso di sé il senso di
identità e di un incontro che può anche
servire a combattere fenomeni per
esempio di criminalità giovanile può
sembrare tutto molto astratto ma ancora
una volta vorrei fare riferimento ad
alcuni esempi che possono aiutarmi a
spiegare tutto questo
il primo è quello del sistema delle
orchestre giovanili del venezuela è un
programma di educazione musicale
gratuita per tutti i bambini di tutti i
ceti che imparano a fare musica imparano
a suonare in questo caso la musica
diventa uno strumento per questi bambini
per imparare ma soprattutto uno
strumento che può eliminare il rischio
di criminalità molto elevato in queste
regioni quindi di nuovo la cultura come
strumento sociale
se pensiamo ai dati a cui facevo
riferimento prima potete possiamo
immaginare che basta misurare il numero
di bambini che prendono parte a questi
concerti il numero i concerti che
vengono dati i premi che queste
orchestre ricevono perché non ricevono i
versi per veri per misurare l'impatto di
queste iniziative
purtroppo temo di no non ci basta
l'altro esempio invece è molto più
vicino a noi un esempio che è avvenuto a
catania a catania da qualche anno è
attiva officine culturali è
un'istituzione associazione che si
occupa della valorizzazione del
monastero dell'ex monastero dei
benedettini sito patrimonio dell'umanità
ma anche sede del dipartimento di
scienze umanistiche e qualche l'anno
scorso
nello staff dell'associazione ha
iniziato un progetto vietato non toccare
destinato alla creazione di un nuovo
percorso per non vedenti
la caratteristica fondamentale di questo
progetto che è stato realizzato in
collaborazione con alcune scuole della
provincia catanese ma solo i ragazzi che
hanno realizzato l'audioguida che
servirà da supporto alle visite guidate
sono i ragazzi che hanno realizzato i
plastici che servono esplorare tattiche
tatti con un contatto scusate le il
monastero dei beni e si tratta
sicuramente di un esempio di co
creazione perché lo staff di uffici e si
è trovato a lavorare insieme ai docenti
di questi ragazzi insieme ai potenziali
fruitori di questi percorsi e
soprattutto insieme a questi ragazzi che
non solo hanno in qualche modo testato
opportunità professionali future ma
dall'altro lato anno si sono confrontati
direttamente con quello che il tema
delle disabilità fisiche e infine un
altro esempio che mi piacerebbe
utilizzare per spiegare questo incontro
da cui deriva la cooperazione la co
creazione è un workshop presentato da
olafur eliasson un artista danese
irlandese l'anno scorso all'ultima
versione di della biennale di venezia e
questo workshop scusatemi
cito perché lui è molto più bravo nello
spiegare cosa fa questo workshop è stato
definito come un atto di accoglienza
rivolto sia a coloro che sono fuggiti
dal disagio dal dall'instabilità nei
loro paesi di origine sia per gli
abitanti delle città che li accolgono
ed è un processo creativo e giocoso i
partecipanti costruiscono delle luci
modulari le green light che sono secondo
l'artista uno strumento per evidenziare
alcune delle sfide delle responsabilità
che derivano dalla crisi dei migranti in
europa e nel resto del mondo quello dei
migranti è un tema molto caro all'arte
alla cultura di questi tempi basta
pensare che anche manifesta di cui
parlavo qualche attimo fa ha come titolo
di nuovo controllo un
un giardino planetario in cui coltivare
la coesistenza quindi l'arte e la
cultura sono fortemente attenti a quelli
che sono dei temi sociali l'aspetto
molto interessante in tutti questi
progetti che definirei di innovazione
culturale e che dall'incontro dalla co
creazione che coinvolge tutti la
comunità locale gli artisti decisori
politici le istituzioni privati e profit
e no profit si nasce qualcosa nascono
dei progetti che servono a combattere a
eliminare quelli che sono conflitti
generazionali culturali sociali
religiosi con questo tipo di progetti si
fa rigenerazione urbana si rigenerano
quartieri ma intere città intere regioni
si riducono se non possiamo di tutto
eliminarli conflitti e problemi sociali
tornando all idea precedente a quanto
detto precedentemente per quanto
riguarda i dati
il problema è che tutto questo tipo
questa gamma di progetti di innovazione
culturale non possono essere definiti
non possono essere misurati
quantitativamente sono veicolo di tutto
un insieme di valori
consentitemi di utilizzare un plurale
non è un solo valore ma è una
combinazione una sfaccettatura di valori
che non possono essere colti con i dati
da economista so bene che se io voglio
misurare gli effetti l'efficienza di un
qualsiasi processo
ho bisogno di conoscere molto bene gli
input e output e misurarli per poter
capire quello che è risultato ma in
tutti questi progetti è molto difficile
a volte determinare quale sia l'imput
cos'è lo le ore di lavoro dello staff di
officine culturali la creatività di
olafur eliasson come riusciamo a
determinare l'input di conseguenza
impensabile cercare di determinare a
volte l'out comunque di misurarlo perché
come dicevo prima non mi basta pensare
al numero di ragazzini che hanno
partecipato a questi progetti ma non mi
basta neanche pensare al numero dei
migranti che hanno partecipato per
esempio quel workshop quindi da questo
emerge quella che ritengo essere una
necessità quella di riuscire in qualche
modo a determinare ad identificare e
definire questi altri valori perché
questi progetti così fluidi così quasi
naturali che nascono dalla cooperazione
e della co creazione fra soggetti così
differenti creano un valore aggiunto
difficile da misurare
ma non meno importante di quello che è
il valore della produzione culturale più
tradizionale quella produzione culturale
che abbiamo detto abbiamo visto fa
riferimento ai numeri dei visitatori per
giustificare l'uso delle risorse
pubbliche ma l'uso di risorse pubbliche
è da giustificare anche per questo tipo
di progetti
proprio perché la cultura è una cultura
per tutti e non può e non deve essere e
l'italia grazie
[Applauso]